- [Voiceover] In a previous video,
we gave an overview of the
light dependent reactions
which are essentially occurring
across the thyla or within
or across the thylakoid membranes,
right that we zoomed in on one
and we saw okay we have
some energy from light
exciting the electrons
within that chlorophyll pair,
that P680 chlorophylled A pair.
That electron, that energized electron
will then be transferred
from one molecule to another
and as it does so it will go to
lower and lower energy states.
And that released energy,
some of it will be used
to transfer hydrogen
protons across the membrane.
And then eventually that
electron will make it's way to
Photo System I where it
can get excited again.
If we think of it as the same electron.
It doesn't necessarily have
to be the exact same electron.
But we can think of that same electron
as being excited again by light energy
and then it can once again go to
lower and lower energy states
and this time it's going to be used
to reduce NADP+ to NADPH.
Now NADPH itself is an
input into the Calvin Cycle.
But ATP is another input we
need for the Calvin Cycle
and the way that we produce ATP
is that hydrogen ion concentration
that increases on the inside due to it
being essentially pumped
across the membrane,
as well as the leftover hydrogen ions
from the water after it's
stripped of electrons,
to replace that originally
excited electron
in that P680 chlorophyll pair.
Well that increased
hydrogen ion concentration
can be used to drive ATP synthase
which creates ATP from phosphate and ADP.
And we saw it, we saw that over here,
without seeing the different components.
You get light, excite the electron.
The electron goes to lower
and lower energy states.
As it does so it's going from
Photo System II to Photo System I.
Some of that energy is being used to
pump hydrogen ions into
the thylakoid lumen.
Then that electron can get excited again
and then as it gets transferred
and goes to lower and lower energy states,
it can be used to produce NADPH
where once again it's electrons
are still at a fairly high energy state
so it's a strong reducing agent.
And so that's why it's
valuable in the Calvin Cycle.
That energy from acting
as a strong reducing agent
can be used to, or help in the creation
or the eventual creation of the sugar.
And once again where as an electron,
once it gives it away,
how does it get replaced?
Well it snags it from the water.
What I have here is a
more detailed diagram
that labels some of the actors
and the important thing is
really what we just covered
and what we covered in more
detail in the previous video.
The conceptual idea of what's happening
in the light dependent reactions.
But a lot of times in your biology class
or in your biology book,
you'll see talk of things
like a cytochrome complex
and plastoquinone and things like that
and I want you to look at that right now
so you're not intimidated when you see it
and that you see that these are
just the actors that we talked about.
So right over here,
this is Photo System II,
and what you have,
and I give credit for where
this image comes from.
It's modified from The
Light Dependent Reactions of
Photosynthesis Figure
8 by OpenStax College.
But this right over here,
we see the light is,
the light is interacting
the way it's depicted here,
not directly with the chlorophyll pair
within Photo System II that,
that P680 chlorophyll A pair.
We see it acting on some of
these neighboring molecules
as their electrons get excited
and then go to lower energy levels,
that energy can be used to
excite neighboring electrons.
This kind of keeps happening.
That energy gets transferred eventually
to excite the electron in that P680 pair
and then that electron, the
first electron acceptor,
you'll see this sometimes spoken of
in your biology textbooks, is pheophytin.
And that can then transfer
the electron to plastoquinone,
and that plastoquinone is interacting
in this cytochrome complex
which transfers the
electron from plastoquinone
to plastocyanin and as it's doing it
you see the hydrogen
ions being transferred
from the outside of the thylakoid
to the inside of the thylakoid,
which is exactly what
we've been talking about.
And then as we go to Photo System I.
Well that electron can
be transferred from the
plastocyanin to the chlorophyll
pair, the P700 chlorophyll.
That can get excited again.
Once again, it doesn't have to be
the light directly exciting it.
It can be exciting other molecules within
the Photo System I,
but that energy eventually
gets transferred
to that chlorophyll,
excites it's electrons
and then it goes from
one molecule to another.
Eventually goes to ferredoxin
which is being used in conjunction.
It's one of the actors that the
enzyme NADP+ reductase
needs along with NADP+.
So it's essentially just reducing NADP+
along with this electron that's
on the ferrodoxin to produce NADPH.
And once again what's going on here?
Well this is the ATP synthase
that is using all this increased
hydrogen ion concentration
on the inside of the thylakoid
to pump or to power the motor,
or the ATP synthase is
the motor that is powered
as these hydrogen ions go down
their concentration gradient.
And that energy is used
to jam the phosphate
on to the ADP to produce ATP.
So I've said essentially the same thing
two or three times already in
the last two or three videos
but I was doing it because
when you first see this
it seems very very intimidating
and very very complex,
and it is complex, and
frankly it's amazing
that things like this are happening
on the plant that I'm looking at
outside my window right now.
It boggles my mind that this kind of
thing is happening in nature.
And there are bits and pieces of it
that aren't fully understood yet
and still need to be discovered.
But at the same time the general idea
is not as intimidating
as these diagrams appear.
So hopefully you find this
awe inspiring, like I do.
And not as intimidating as what
some of these words might
make you feel initially.